why does salt dissolve in water but oil
doesn't well in a word chemistry but
that's not very satisfying is it well
the reason salt dissolves and oil does
not comes down to the two big reasons
why anything happens at all energetics
and entropy energetics deals primarily
with the attractive forces between
things when we look at oil or salt in
water we focus on the forces between
particles on a very very very small
scale the molecular level to give you a
sense of this scale in one glass of
water there are more molecules than
known stars in the universe now all of
these molecules are in constant motion
moving vibrating and rotating what
prevents almost all of those molecules
from just flying out of the glass are
the attractive interactions between
molecules the strength of the
interactions between water itself and
other substances is what we mean when we
say energetics you can think the water
molecules engaging in a constant dance
sort of like a square dance where they
constantly and randomly exchange
partners put simply the ability for
substances to interact with water
balance with how they disrupt how water
interacts with itself plays an important
role in explaining why certain things
mix well into water and others don't
entropy basically describes the way
things and energy can be arranged based
on random motion for example think of
the air in a room imagine all the
different possible Arrangements in space
for the trillions of particles
the air some of those arrangements might
have all the oxygen molecules over here
and all the nitrogen molecules over
there separated but far more of the
possible arrangements have those
molecules mixed up with one so entropy
favors mixing energetics deals with
attractive forces and so if attractive
forces are present the probability of
some arrangements can be enhanced the
ones where things are attracted to each
other so it is always the balance of
these two things that determines what
happens on the molecular level water is
comprised of water molecules made up of
two hydrogen atoms and an oxygen as
liquid water these molecules are engaged
in a constant and random square dance
that is called the hydrogen bonding
Network entropy favors keeping the
square dance going at all times there
are always more ways that all the water
molecules can arrange in the square
dance as compared to if the water
molecules did a line dance
so the square dance constantly goes on
so what happens when you put salt in the
water well on a molecular level salt is
actually made up of two different ions
chlorine and sodium that are organized
like a brick wall they show up to the
dance as a big group in formation and
sit on the side at first shy and a bit
reluctant to break apart into individual
ions to join the dance but secretly
those shy dancers just want someone to
ask them to join so when a water
randomly bumps into one of them and
pulls them into the dance away from
their group they go and once they go
into the dance they don't come back out
and in fact the addition of the salt
ions adds more possible dance positions
in the square dance so it is favored for
them to stay dancing with water now
let's take with oil the molecules are
sort of interested in dancing with water
so entropy favors them joining the dance
the problem is that oil molecules are
wearing gigantic ball gowns and they're
way bigger than water molecules so when
an oil molecule gets pulled in their
size is really disruptive to the dance
and the random exchange of partners that
the water is engaging
very important part of it is in addition
they are not great dancers the water
molecules try to engage the oil
molecules in the dance but they just
keep bumping into their dresses and
taking up all the room on the dance
floor there are way more ways the waters
can dance when the oil gets off the
floor so the waters squeeze out the oil
pushing it back to the bench with the
others pretty soon when a large number
of oils have been squeezed over to the
side they band together to commiserate
about how unfair the waters are being
and stick together as a group so it is
this combination of the interactions
between molecules and the configurations
available to them when they're moving
randomly that dictates whether they mix
in other words water and oil don't mix
because they just don't make great dance
partners